the US has begun a massive bombing
campaign on Iranian revolutionary guard
Targets in Syria and Iraq basically
ladies and gentlemen the US has just
begun a very long protracted war in the
Middle East surprise surprise where have
we heard this one before I'm not
surprised it's happening but the
question is how will it escalate I
believe that the news we're seeing here
is basically it's a unilateral
declaration of war by Joe Biden we are
now attacking Iran the questions are why
is Iranians revolutionary why is Iranian
revolutionary guard operating in Syria
and Iraq and when did we declare war on
Syria and why are we there anyway I
think the uh unip Party The
Establishment realized you know the
problem isn't that we unilaterally
declare war and everyone complains about
it they're complaining about it because
we told them we did so now they're just
just go do it ignore it and don't talk
about it